himesh would you tell us about some of
the challenges of this project well it
was really hard to bring the tame to the
innuendo otherwise no I mean to do we
didn't have production to go along with
so it was sort of like you imagined what
the guys were actually saying but there
was just big blank and you had the words
and you had the space and you sort of
had the lips moving along and then you
sort of imagined what they really wanted
to sound like in that moment of sweet
sweet tame innuendo and and that's what
you went for but it was it was super
tricky actually yeah and you all
recorded separately right so is that
something you're used to doing you know
going to a session by yourself and
having to did you have lines from the
other actor how dude went first and how
did that work did you have anything you
go I went first and so he had like the
scenes with Lily they were not there so
you had to pretty much sort of imagine
what was what Lily was saying yeah yeah
I sort of set the tone for the whole for
the whole project I said the bar will go
like this see no it yeah it was
wonderful you really sort of jump out
without a net but um it's really cool
though you know and it is like it is
such an aspirational period you do I
didn't want to be making that movie for
real you know does movies that period
and as we just saw you know this magic I
loved the way they moved there well so
much of the body movements and also the
the mouth I found when we were working
together I kept on trying to get my
mouth in this special way and sort of so
sensuous and a charming and you know the
women were coquettish in a way that we
now is not allowed to be the same you
know in the same sense and I just I was
I walked out of there feeling very alive
let's put it that way for me was the the
the speed and the lightness of the
comedy you know comedy can be quite
indulgent
and and and i think it's just quick
snappy one-liners it's a great will to
leap into but it's a difficult word to
keep pace with because we work at a
different pace i think nowadays and then
the other big challenge was that the
film is so old and grainy that it's hard
to actually see the way the math is
working often so you're effing taking a
leap of imagination there too